hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one key aspect of
the stoic approach to human beings and
their relationships with each other
their situatedness within communities
and also their place in the larger scope
of the universe is an attitude that we
can call cosmopolitanism they're not the
first people to come up with that word
as a matter of fact you see some of the
cynics Diogenes for example talking
about himself being a holy chase a
citizen of the cosmos which can be
understood as the order the world or the
universe now the question that we want
to think about is what does it really
mean to be a citizen of the world what
does it mean to have the world as one's
community or as one's city is is how we
could actually translate it so there's a
lot of the aspects to this that you see
running throughout that matiee toises
discourses he doesn't have a chapter
specifically on cosmopolitanism but it's
something that he sets forth as an ideal
and I'd like to read you one short
passage that gives you sort of a good
starting point this isn't book 3 it's
chapter 4 24 he says shall we not mean
ourselves
at last and call to mind what we have
heard from the philosophers if indeed we
did not listen to them as some chanters
when they said that this university has
bought a single state but a single
organization and the substance out of
which it has been fashioned a single and
it must needs be that there is a certain
periodic change in a giving place of one
thing to another and that some things be
dissolved and others come into being
some things to remain at the same place
others to be moved that's one way to
think about it he talks about taking a
very broad point of view where we see
the whole universe not only the earth
itself the whole universe as one giant
system that we're all parts of now when
you adopt that sort of point of view it
makes the things that were engaged in as
individuals as specific people seem
rather small and so I want to clarify
from the beginning that cosmopolitanism
does not mean not attending to one
specific relationship so if one is a
child or a parent a brother or sister a
friend these things actually matter
they're not lost or swallowed up within
the great whole as a matter of fact we
make our contribution to the entire
cosmos by how we conduct ourselves in
these determinate relationships that we
have been given they have there are a
lot of many ways are dependent on what
might appear to be chance the Stoics
would actually say Providence would
think the fact that I was born in this
place the fact that I went to school
with this person and became friends with
them all those sorts of things the fact
that I lived next door to this person as
my my neighbor so it doesn't mean that
we don't attend to our individual duties
that are indicated to us by our roles
and relation
as a matter of fact what it means is
that we adopt a broader and fuller
perspective in which those can have
their their real meaning and in many
respects if we isolate ourselves against
the rest of humanity just within our
little nuclear family or a blended
family or whatever kind of family we
have or our circle of friends our clique
or our neighborhood or even our nation
we are in a certain sense not living a
full life we are not being part of that
that grand connection and communication
with all other rational beings and even
the rest of the cosmos living things you
know beautiful things that we can
experience things that we could we can
improve so it's really about adopting
this broader and fuller perspective one
aspect of this that connects directly to
these specific relationships is that we
should view and treat others equally as
parts or as children of God this is you
you might say this is a very religious
point of view Epictetus is probably one
of the most religious of the Stoics it's
not quite the same thing as the kind of
spirituality or a religiousness that you
would expect from Christians and Jews
and Muslims but there are some things in
common with it he does think that we are
all of us as individuals as human beings
at least in the higher part of ourselves
the Faculty of choice the rationality we
are parts of God we contain the divine
within ourselves so that means that when
I not only take care of the divine
within me but I say not you know eating
too much and not mixing it with with you
know indiscriminate sexuality or the
sorts of things that he talks about in
another video
by the human relationships of the divine
we also want to think about the other
people that were encountering as equally
that way so I can honor the divine in
another person by treating them in the
way that they ought to be treated by me
as a rational being that doesn't mean
that they're going to actually exercise
their rationality
he has got plenty of examples you know
he's his father and brother in this
business prime examples where perhaps
your father doesn't treat you the way a
father should but you treat your father
the way that you ought to in part
because you're treating your father is
something more than just that
mean-spirited sob that you're dealing
with right or the same thing with your
sibling your brother is trying to
deprive you of your share of the estate
or you know that's not so common these
days but your brother's trying to get
more attention than you and taking up
more of your parents time than you know
really he deserves and he thinks that
he's doing just the right thing and
doing so well you don't have control
over that but you can still treat your
brother as somebody who matters
Epictetus actually extends this as far
as how we treat those who are in
subordinate positions to ourselves in
the ancient times they had slavery or
servitude in our time we have you know
people who are subordinated to us in
different ways people who are you know
working for us perhaps or who have to
deal with us and do we treat them the
way that they ought to be treated or do
we treat them as somehow lesser and were
their feelings their thoughts don't
don't matter this is a very important
consideration so if we're doing that
then we are going to be attending to our
specific duties our specific
relationships and our roles and we're
going to place it in a larger context
it's not just about you know what's
going on between me and that person it's
not just about how you know that's
affecting me or tie
either it's about the broader community
that were part of in the better parts of
that community that they are equally a
member of whether they're using it or
not as we are perhaps they're actually
using it for kind of thing another way
that he talks about it is that for the
person who actually desires to be a part
of it if we open our eyes we are part of
a divine household a Commonwealth a a
state that contains all sorts of friends
for us humans and gods God with a small
G meaning the great you know powerful
things that help keep the universe going
I suppose but any sort of rational being
that really wants to be rational we can
be friends with epictetus thinks that
that wars and stripes arise between us
in part because we prioritize our own
interest which is a legitimate thing our
own self-interest we prioritize that
over everything else and we think that
that's where our genuine good lies all
the time to the exclusion of others and
so things are allowed to come between us
I've done video about that as well that
you can take a look at so you know when
nations go to war with each other it's
because they're not being cosmopolitan
they're not treating each other as if
they they are all genuinely part of one
great household one great the economy
weakling or economic a in the Greek
another thing that he says is that one
can live well anywhere and I've got a
few passages that I want to bring up
from from that in boat to chapter 16 he
has a personal lamenting when then shall
I see Athens once more and the Acropolis
and he says poor man are you're not
satisfied with what you see
every day have you anything finer or
greater to look at than the sun the moon
the stars the whole earth the sea and if
you really understand him who governs
the universe and bear him about within
you do you not yearn for bits do not yet
yearn for bits of stone one had a pretty
rock meaning the Acropolis when
therefore you are about to leave the
sudden moon what will you do will you
sit and cry as little children cry why
are you calling yourself a philosopher
if that's the case we can live well
pretty much anywhere
there will be more challenges of course
in many places but if we can pour
ourselves as rational beings we can get
along with anybody else who wants to be
rational and the universe itself is full
of wonderful things that we can
collaborate with them and cooperate with
a little bit later he says this is a
book 3 chapter 24 again all things are
full of friends first gods and then also
men who by nature have been made one
household with another and that some men
must remain with each other others must
depart and then though we must rejoice
and those who dwell with us yet we must
not grieve at those who depart we not
only have to be willing to accept in our
own capacity to live well anywhere but
we also need to understand that other
people require them as well that perhaps
they need to go somewhere and we
shouldn't center it entirely on
ourselves and how we feel and how we
reflected we should understand ourselves
as part of a larger system again just to
stress this is the last point kind of
Napolitan ISM doesn't mean that we don't
focus on the particular that we don't
care about any of the parts but it means
adopting this broader view in which we
are able to see things the way that at
least to a certain extent God might see
them where each thing
and each thing has its place and each
thing is connected up with everything
else